wir haben jetzt die ganze darauf
gewartet ob sie sich auf irgendwas
einigen konnten oder das am ende doch
nur ein appell war paul faß einer für
uns zusammen was jetzt am ende dabei
raus zu kommen es vor allem wie auch die
stimmung war jetzt heiliger
pressekonferenz das war gar nichts das
war peinlich naive feige schönrednerei
die haben sich der sechs stunden
versammelt und kommen dann raus und
erzählen den bürgern das was sie dort
gerade erzählt haben finde ich geht gar
nicht so eine schlechte presse konferenz
habe ich während diesen
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz noch nie
erlebt in wahrheit haben sie sich nur
gestritten das wollten sie nicht zugeben
natürlich obwohl herr müller so ein
bisschen erwähnt hat ja das kanzleramt
da kann man vielleicht mal über die
vorlage reden
die kanzlerin wollte sich auch nicht
darauf einlassen dass man sich doch
irgendwie nicht eins war und markus
söder nur betont na ja man hätte das ein
oder andere umsetzen können das muss man
dann in der zukunft was sie nicht
beantwortet haben verdammt noch mal
entweder ist man sich einig dass es
verschärfungen braucht wieso hat man es
nicht geschafft das heute umzusetzen
oder man ist sich einig dass man diese
verschärfung nicht braucht dann braucht
man aber auch nicht sagen in einer woche
müssen wir dann also wir haben dort
etwas überlegt erlebt man hätte sich
eigentlich gar nicht treffen müssen wozu
denn also wozu haben sich dort jetzt die
ministerpräsidenten die auch viel zu tun
haben normalerweise sechs stunden
unterhalten
ich verstehe dass überhaupt nicht wie
man dann raus gehen kann und noch nicht
mal alle journalistenfragen beantworten
will also es war die kürzeste
pressekonferenz denn die kanzlerin
musste sich natürlich noch unangenehme
fragen einstellen also das war wirklich
peinlich und ich habe während dieser
ministerpräsident konferenz mit einigen
teilnehmern gesprochen die das gleiche
gesagt haben gesagt dass wir heute
wirklich einfach schlecht ja das sind
sehr deutliche und sehr klare worte und
sehen wir mal wieder drauf wie sind
nächste woche nächste woche da haben wir
ein bisschen mehr zeit das hat ja was
soll daran erinnern ich sagen hertha ist
das jetzt eine pandemie die so
dramatisch ist ich glaube natürlich sie
ist dramatisch aber dann muss ich doch
den bürgern erklären warum ich dann erst
in einer woche handeln muss deswegen ist
die frage wie groß ist überhaupt die
hoffnung dass das nächste woche besser
wird na ja ich glaube schon dass die
länder natürlich unter druck sind jetzt
dadurch dass sie sozusagen eigene
vorschläge machen
das hängt sicherlich ab von der zahl
aber ich finde auch man hätte viel
klarer auch in dieser pressekonferenz
machen müssen wenn man denn der
überzeugung ist wie herr müller
möglicherweise aber auch das hat er
nicht erklären können dass man das jetzt
noch nicht braucht dann hätte man ja
darauf verweisen können und sagen können
okay wir haben hoffnung weil die zahlen
sich abgesenkt haben aber auch das hat
man nicht getan deshalb die bürger
stehen vor ganz großen fragezeichen
keiner versteht warum die sich dort
heute sechs stunden versammelt haben und
dann so eine peinliche show abliefern
ja wir wollen jetzt noch einmal vor das
kanzleramt schauen dort ist unser
kollege peter tiede der aber nach den
sechs stunden jetzt anscheinend dann
auch für den moment die pause gebraucht
hat also peter tiede für uns nicht vor
dem kanzleramt
das ist wahrscheinlich auch geschockt
davon dass wir wirklich sechs stunden im
live-ticker diesen streit erleben und
ich finde das wirklich nicht in ordnung
dass die kanzlerin auch den journalisten
gegenüber damit meine ich jetzt nicht
unsere kollegen ja sondern diejenigen
die dort drei stunden gewartet haben
weil sich ministerpräsidenten streiten
und die kanzlerin
und dann noch nicht mal die fragen
beantworten will das finde ich geht
einfach nicht in so einer situation denn
da hat die kanzlerin auch den verdammten
auftrag den menschen zu erklären was
dort eigentlich passiert sind die
menschen sind verunsichert sie wissen
nicht ist es jetzt so schlimm oder ist
es nicht so schlimm
und das muss bitte schön erklärt werden
wir haben das jetzt auch einmal ganz
konkret auf den punkt zu bringen was
gerade gesagt das war gar nichts aber es
hat sich jetzt auch nichts geändert also
bis kommende woche bleibt alles wird das
ist die übersetzung von gar nichts du
diese kennt nur um das nochmal ganz klar
zumal mit wenigstens wieder der filiale
abholen nochmal sich weniger zu
versammeln es gibt den appell sich nur
mit einer person zu treffen aber es gibt
keine massnahmen es gibt keine
entwicklung bei den schulen all die
dinge die die kanzlerin wollte gab es
nicht aber ich verstehe nicht warum man
sich dann in so einem diplomatischen
gemurre verstecken will und nicht
einfach klar sagt was sache ist und wenn
man sich dort sechs stunden streitet und
wir über diesen streit berichten
dann kann die kanzlerin ja auch klar
sagen das ist meine position und wenn
herr müller die position hat das ist
noch nicht so schlimm ist dann soll er
in dieser pressekonferenz doch sagen wie
es sieht also ich fand das sehr sehr
enttäuschend und insgesamt peinlich mehr
nachrichten und breaking news nur bei
der schau dir das nächste video an und
vergiss nicht zu abonnieren